if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to 200 off and two
free pillows at helixsleep.com
pacman
so the big news the big news cycle over
the last 16 18 hours or so is that it is
here it is here omicron
has been confirmed in the united states
now is this meaningful we don't know
is it
newsworthy in the sense of
is it surprising it's probably already
been here for some weeks
um and number three
does this
finding make us question
the
prudency
of the travel bans that have been put in
place we're going to talk about all of
these different questions but the big
news and we're kind of in the
omnichrome
now i'm saying it the way now i'm saying
it the way biden said it the other day
omicron which
joe biden referred to as the omnicron
omicron is here
uh in the united states and now we're in
the omicron found in this state and soon
omicron found in that state phase of the
story without yet knowing what that
actually means so uh cnbc reporting
yesterday cdc confirms first case of
omicron covet variant in california
the cdc said wednesday it confirmed the
first u.s case of the new heavily
mutated coronavirus variant called
omicron detected in northern california
white house chief medical advisor
anthony fauci
said the patient who was fully
vaccinated had just returned to the san
francisco area november 22nd after
traveling in south africa tested
positive november 29.
the end of again the timing given that
they got back at this point what is that
eight ten days ago
suggests it's probably been here for
some time the individual is
self-quarantining and all close contacts
have been contacted and thus far have
tested negative we feel good that this
patient not only had mild symptoms but
actually had the symptoms appear to be
improving
uh that is good news
um
the article because it is cnbc mentions
that there was a big swing in the stock
market yesterday after this case was
confirmed and this is one of those
things where it's sort of like
really guys like the idea is that at any
time the stock market reflects all
known information about the state of the
economy uh or companies that are at
least measured by the stock stock market
is it really news that there was one
case found in the united states i mean
when when almost a week ago or even
longer you know about a week ago we said
it's probably already here
uh
a
500 plus point swing because of the
announcement seems to me like not a
particularly efficient market given that
any reasonable person would have
inferred
there's going to be cases here and we
still don't yet know how serious they
are now that's the next thing that i
want to talk about
we are starting to anecdotally get
information about the believed severity
of omicron cases and whether this means
we're headed in some kind of terrible
direction or whether this might actually
be a milder variant there are more and
more
even from this morning anecdotal claims
that
those who are vaccinated
don't really have to worry more about
omicron whatever level you were worried
before is the level you should be
worried now but that if you're
unvaccinated you should worry we're
starting to see more and more that story
is being told more and more although it
is not yet a story that we can
definitively confirm
for example south africa expert previous
infection doesn't protect against
omicron but shots do
people infected with earlier variants of
covid do not appear to be protected
against omicron but vaccination will
prevent serious illness a top south
african scientist says we believe that
previous infection does not provide
protection from omicron says ann von
gottberg expert at the national
institute for communicable diseases in
south africa outlining early research
into the newly emerged variant she says
doctors are seeing an increase for
omicron re-infections we believe the
number of cases will increase
exponentially in all provinces of the
country that's south africa with a low
vaccination level we believe that
vaccines will still however protect
against severe disease that's really the
whole story at this point in time so now
let's kind of summarize
omicron has been here for weeks this is
an individual
who came back from south africa november
22nd if we believe that they brought it
from south africa rather than we don't
know what their connection was maybe
they got it from someone else it's it's
in a whole bunch of countries and it
already was on november 22nd it's likely
been here for weeks
um number two
the um
question as to whether it is milder or
not remains an open question because
with every claim right now there is a
counter claim most of the cases in south
africa are mild well but most of the
cases in south africa are in young
people so far that we know of and you
need 10 14 days to see what the disease
progression is uh well a lot of the
cases in south africa are in the
unvaccinated well
that's because a lot of the young are
unvaccinated in south africa it is is
one the cause or is one the effect we
just don't know at this point in time
um
is it not more deadly
on an infection fatality rate basis
but by being more transmissible more
people will die because more people will
get it right we don't know the answer to
that at this point in time do vaccines
protect at all against serious disease
well what about the third dose if you
have the third dose are you more
protected against omicron it seems so
from early data but we still don't know
and then the third piece of this is what
does this mean about travel bans because
there is at this point a situation where
south africa did the right thing by
saying hey we sequenced this we found
this this is a new variant and oh well
it came from south africa it's now not
even totally clear
it might have come from european
countries and it might have been brought
to south because south africa was the
first to say it
south africa and southern africa are
being punished in terms of travel bans
when it's everywhere anyway right the
travel bans seem to
happen at a time when it's already
spread they are of unclear efficacy at
actually doing the thing they're
supposed to do and by the time we have
this much information it seems to
already be too late so there's a real
question as to uh the wisdom of these
kind of targeted travel bans um
everything remains preliminary
and the people who haven't been paying
attention or modifying their behavior or
getting vaccinated all along
are generally speaking not going to do
anything differently i do believe that
even
the hyperbolic claims which are not yet
backed by evidence about omicron will
get some people who are unvaccinated to
go and get vaccinated but not a whole
bunch of them curious to hear from you
if you agree
stacy abrams has announced she is again
going to run for georgia governor in
2022
this is actually sort of exciting i have
to tell you i kind of like this the
atlanta journal constitution reporting
stacy abrams is running for governor in
2022
she launched her campaign yesterday with
a pledge to fight for economic equality
and expand health care access setting up
a potential rematch against republican
governor brian kemp in one of the
nation's most competitive political
backgrounds uh battlegrounds rather so
what does that mean potentially a
rematch remember that there was this
crazy situation where
stacey abrams ran stacey abrams democrat
ran against brian kemp republican
in georgia for the governorship and
brian kemp won
what was crazy about that race is that
at the time brian kemp was the secretary
of state of georgia meaning that brian
kemp as secretary of state was
overseeing the election in which the
same brian kemp republican candidate for
governor was a candidate absolutely
insane allegations of foul play running
rampant and uh
many concerns that it could be even
worse this time because of something
called sb 202 which we're going to talk
about in a moment now why is it a
possible rematch against brian kemp for
stacey abrams well it's possible because
first stacey abrams has to win her
democratic primary in georgia and
secondly because brian kemp has to win
his republican primary now you could say
david these both of those things are
likely to happen i wouldn't disagree
with you but we don't yet know uh for
sure kemp has announced he's running for
re-election
now it's it's cliche at this point to
say it
but
the outcome will likely depend on
turnout as it often does in these state
races
and um we now
certainly have to talk about sb 202
sb 202
is a
voting
law
how can i even say it's a voting rules
law comprehensive that affects a bunch
of different aspects of voting in the
state of georgia for example
as of sb 202 which was passed after
stacey abrams lost that race the
earliest voters can request mail-in
ballots is 11 weeks before the election
instead of 180 days that's like less
than half as much time
the final deadline to complete an
application for a mail-in ballot has
been moved earlier
counties will start mailing out the
absentee ballots about three weeks later
than before
starting only four weeks before the
election so they're compressing and
limiting
the ways and schedules on which people
can make
can vote absentee and request those
ballots requesting and returning a
ballot will also be subject to new
stricter voter id
rules there are changes to early voting
which in fulton county which is a key
democratic county
you will no longer be able to use one of
two
mobile voting buses in that county uh
which were purchased to help with long
lines access to those is being
restricted so that's not good for
democrats so
the plus of this
potential rematch between stacey abrams
and brian kemp is brian kemp won't also
be the secretary of state running the
election that's good for stacey abrams
not so good for stacey abrams as sb 202
which is
a series of changes that on balance do
not help it
forget about do not help hurt democrats
straight up hurt democrats i think
stacey abrams is a great candidate and
one of the things she has going for her
since she last ran are some major
successes when you look at the two
what was the date now january 5th of
this year
special senate elections in which rafael
warnock and uh john ossoff won defeating
republican incumbents stacey abrams gets
much of the credit for those wins
participating in massive voter
registration efforts successful ones at
that
i think she's a very solid candidate she
speaks to voters in a way that is both
relatable
but not from a condescending place
but also really clearly uh she in that
sense she's an interesting kind of uh um
uh
has an interesting delivery and way to
that she relates to voters i'm so i'm
very excited about this race we've got
the texas gubernatorial race where beto
o'rourke is running and there's real
questions as to whether he's the right
candidate i actually think that stacey
abrams is the right candidate in georgia
and uh we're going to be following that
race many close very closely the the
midterms are really shaping up to be
very interesting i was speaking to our
youtube rep yesterday and i said
at first i didn't know from like a
public interest standpoint how
interested will will our audience and
the country be in these midterm
elections
now as a lot of these specific races are
starting to take shape
this could be one of the most followed
midterm elections overall
um in a very very long time
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter deepakman remember that
december 14th at 6 pm eastern will be
doing the next david pakman show viewer
town hall it will be streaming live on
our second youtube channel pacman live
make sure you're subscribed there we'll
take a break and be back with much more
after this
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video remember that you can join
the discussion on the david pakman show
subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit i want to look at a couple of
posts that i spotted this morning um
this this is really funny because this
is this is now becoming an ongoing issue
uh this post says david your videos on
youtube no longer display the number of
dislikes i guess youtube has finally
rolled this feature out is there no way
of opting out so we can visibly see the
dislikes i feel that having dislikes not
shown may lead some in the audience to
believe david is hiding the dislikes oh
it's not it may i am getting emails
voicemails and tweets saying david
you coward
hiding your dislikes in order
guys youtube rolled out this policy i
did nothing i did nothing
um
the post goes on to say it creates an
issue surrounding a channel's
transparency
to allow dislikes and negative reception
i know david would never try to silence
his audience in this manner but this
decision by youtube may have a blowback
effect on channel like david's with
people commenting dislike or why did you
remove the dislikes it's not that it may
people are already saying why did you
remove dislikes we have no control over
it this was a youtube decision i could
not care less about it i already was
never looking at the dislikes i actually
could there it's funny the um about a
month and a half ago
i was looking through our video manager
and i saw
you could rank videos by the percentage
likes and in general our videos have
like 95 percent likes or something like
that and i was like huh
i could be looking to see what videos
have more dislikes if i cared about it
and then i just moved on so the idea
that i'm even looking at dislikes is
kind of funny um to begin with
but uh yeah it has nothing to do with
anything we've done it's a youtube
policy and that's basically it
um next post what exactly is this open
border does anyone know this argument
we've all heard conservatives point to
this crazy unruly open border that's
biden's fault what changed at the border
i've never seen the u.s under any
president have an open border and i
don't understand the argument aren't we
still deporting people and turning them
away isn't the process to get
citizenship highly complex and lengthy i
always hear people say we have an open
border and we give immigrants money
health care and education
where exactly is that happening is this
all made up or is there some factual
basis for the claim so the truth is
there has been nothing it's actually
mentioned in a comment in this reddit
post we've had nothing approximating an
open border of any kind for about a
hundred years there are countries that
do um
although i'm not up to exactly where it
stands right now my birth country of
argentina
um
for a long time i'm not going to say
it's exactly this way now because i'm
not sure but for a long time anyone
could basically go and assuming that
within i don't remember it was a year or
two you either are able to get enrolled
in a university
or are able to find a job
that's your path to legal status in
argentina now it's not like argentina is
the u.s and everybody's trying to go to
argentina not that everybody's trying to
go to the us but there's a lot more
people trying to come to the u.s than to
go to argentina but no the post is right
there is not an open border even the
process for requesting asylum is
not a particularly short or easy process
there is no open border and it's just
another one of these vapid right-wing
talking points that works on a lot of
people
lastly
david sir
if the supreme court rules against roe v
wade does biden have a green light to
expand the court
we can make the case that morally
uh joe biden
has a case to expand and pack the
supreme court we can make a case that
legally and politically he does but i
don't think he's going to do it if you
give me as i like to say i'm not a
betting man but if you give me an even
money bet does joe biden add justices to
the supreme court i'm taking the no i
think it's i i just don't think he has
any interest in doing it um if you
disagree with me certainly let me know
and you can join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit more than uh we're we're around i
think 33 000 of our viewers and
listeners are subscribed to the
subreddit great place
for respectful discussion of politics
and news davidpakman.com reddit okay
this is super interesting there are
hundreds of cases against alleged trump
rioters from january 6 right now
hundreds of cases
um
there has now been a decision by the
judge in the case to release the police
interrogation video of one of the
accused rioters a man named danny
rodriguez danny rodriguez many in my
audience thought this was like a kid
like barely an adult i did two turns out
it's a 38 year old man
danny rodriguez has admitted to being
the individual who tased
officer michael fanon who was one of the
three or four officers who testified
before the committee investigating the
january 6th riots we're going to look at
some clips of the police interviews uh
some call them interrogations and
they're interesting in a number of ways
in terms of the police interviewing
techniques they are all completely
standard when i streamed some of these
clips yesterday there were people in the
chat saying everything here is crazy
that the police are doing and others
saying this is all totally standard
everything that happens here is
completely standard it doesn't mean we
like all of it but it is all completely
standard let's jump in here is when he
has first read his miranda rights and
danny rodriguez says you know i'm always
told i'm not supposed to talk
i want to talk to you guys in
the past lawyers have always told me you
know you don't say anything
well look by signing this
you're just acknowledging that you read
your rights and that you're willing to
talk to us at this time just because you
signed it doesn't mean any of these
rights go away these rights are always
with you throughout the entire process
that you're in the legal system okay
does that make sense all right so
totally standard danny signs
acknowledges that he's been read his
rights and then does proceed to talk
although he seems sort of hesitant in
this next moment the officers do
something that's very very typical
and i'm not saying this is good or bad
it's very very typical they say listen
we want your side of the story because
right now we're getting everybody else's
side and we want your side of the story
the implication is always that you can
help yourself by telling your side of
the story now
defense lawyers will tell you
it's never in your interest to just
start talking in this way
you really want to make them have to
prove their case against you now this
guy ultimately admits what he did and
there's video evidence and whatever but
just merely you know for people saying
oh well he's being trick this is typical
we want to hear your side of the story
every defense attorney i know would say
get a lawyer don't say a word and get a
lawyer this is an opportunity here for
you to
let us know and help us understand
because right now we don't we don't
frankly understand
exactly what happened from your
perspective right and
i think that
there's an opportunity here for us to
get clarity on what what went down and
what you and these are always the terms
that
investigators use
this is an opportunity for you most
people hear opportunity that that sounds
good
uh we can get we can clear this up let's
clear this up and
good police interviewers already have
the clarity they need from evidence and
other people they've spoken to and what
they mean by clarity is getting you to
admit that this is the thing uh that you
did so then they get on to some pretty
interesting substances substantive stuff
substantive stuff why did danny
rodriguez start going to rallies in the
first place trump rallies and other
right-wing rallies well among other
things it was alex jones and infowars uh
take a listen to this
and and so
i think that's kind of what
what i'm trying to like understand
i don't know what happened either
is
i want to know that danny though
i want to know
i want to know that danny that
you know that kind of intervened in that
situation and i want to know how that
danny got
to
january 6th
your story is an important
story i just think that
um
and by the way that line your story is
an important story i got a couple of
emails from defense lawyers who said
without saying anything about this
particular guy
oftentimes
people in these situations
don't
really
understand what's going on and that the
detectives are there only if they
believe you did it um to be able to
build that case against you to
ultimately have this go to trial and get
a conviction
this idea of your story is an important
story
more sophisticated individuals i mean
listen if i was sitting there i would go
stop blowing smoke or you know you know
where
an important story what do you do i look
like an idiot to you an important i mean
it's just it's an it's but it works and
that's why they say stuff like this is
an important story i seem crazy you're
like a conspiracy theorist because you
guys are it's gonna come out and i'm
gonna get locked up because like i
believe this and it's gonna put me in
jail
okay
um so continuing to uh ask those
questions and um he does for the most
part uh
continue talking about it and then they
get to this part about uh alex jones
let's take a listen to that we've done
this for a long time we've talked to
like i told you we talked to a lot of
people
and a lot of people um
are worried about being judged when they
talk to law enforcement that we're going
to have
an opinion
and i'm telling you right now
we don't we don't hold judgment over you
we want we could be the jury and the
judge you know it's going to be like
even even as
a fellow human being right
that's what we're telling you we're
looking at you today as a as a fellow
human as a fellow citizen of this
country as somebody who has lived here
and put an investment into this country
of your your work and your
you grew up here and
look
i don't have any loyalty to any other
country such as america this is all i
know and this is all i want
and i don't care about
any other part of the world except for
our team
so how how did the danny
that stood
on the line in between law enforcement
and antiqua blm how did you get get to
that point what happened in your life
like
how did you start going to these rallies
so like alex jones stuff
yeah okay
alex jones and infowars is what started
to radicalize him
in this direction now maybe the most
contentious aspect of this
is that his lawyers are now claiming
he signaled he didn't want to talk
by shaking his head at one point during
the interview and i'm going to show that
to you and this is pretty early on
and so his lawyer is asking that
everything including the eventual
confession i'm going to play for you be
thrown out now i'm going to play the
video for you where he shakes his head
he absolutely shakes his head
very slightly
and then
he does continue talking i'm going to
tell you in a moment the case that his
lawyers are making if you're watching
it's all i've had to watch it 10 times
to even see this he very very slightly
shakes his head here okay so let's pay
very close attention and see if you can
spot it
do you want to talk about that
okay
so he's asked do you want to talk about
that it's a very very slight head shake
very very slight i'll play it one more
time it's barely visible
you want to talk about that
because i tell you what
everybody else is going to talk about
that yeah
i'm pretty ashamed
so what happens is he's asked do you
want to talk about that it's a very
slight head shake and then he's told
everyone else is going to talk about it
and then he says well i'm ashamed and
then he continues talking
it's incredibly subtle the argument that
his lawyers are making is everything
after that is inadmissible because when
a
suspect
says they don't want to talk
they can resume talking under their own
choice
but they have to be the ones doing it
and this is the argument his lawyers are
making and because the detective then
said well everyone else is going to talk
about it the lawyers are saying that is
continuing to question him even though
it's not literally a question that they
continued even though he shook his head
this i spoke to a couple defense lawyers
they
they're saying this is very very
50 50.
um but that if they had to guess
this is not going to be a confession
that is thrown out on the basis of that
slight head shake but that's what his
lawyers are arguing for now then you get
to a key moment which is where he says
yes i tased him he tased officer fanon
this is sort of like the key moment of
the confession
he's a human being with children
and he's he's he's not a bad guy he
sounds like he's just doing his job and
so here it starts to sound like there's
some aspect of remorse i'll get back to
that here he says he was in dc because
as far as he knew trump called them to
dc
how do you get to
january 6 like how what's what else
happens in that period of time
how did he let you guys know to come to
dc
if he's the commander-in-chief and the
leader of our country
and he's calling for help
i thought he was calling for help
i thought he was
i thought we were doing the right thing
so we were just
i had no plans of what was gonna happen
i didn't know what was gonna happen so
he believed trump was calling them he
believed trump was calling him and then
it did get emotionally escalated and
there was kind of this kind of breakdown
feel to it danny did you feel like you
were
the three percent
here like like
like those people
that
stormed the capital that
those were patriots those are people who
are doing that because they were the
three percent that were going to
free our country from
fraudulent
politicians and schemes
of evil people so that way we could
have a
republic that was going to be whole
again is that what you thought
you thought you were that three percent
guy
i know man
i know it's okay
i'm sorry guys no we we know look look
listen
we know you thought that you were that
three percent guy i'm so sorry i did so
this is interesting for a number of
different reasons one this is just one
story of the hundreds there are hundreds
of people like this who they believed
that they were patriots they believed
trump was calling them to dc they
believed they were doing the right thing
by tasering or tasing a police officer
and on and on and on number two in
moments he sort of seems remorseful
but
then in other moments you realize he
actually isn't he talks about he and his
patriots is there going to be room in
the jail for how the number of patriots
that are there
he uh still continues to insist that
they were doing generally speaking the
right thing so
what this one story tells us i don't
know but understand that when we say
stochastic terrorism people see these
messages all this different stuff and it
leads to real world action
it very much does and every single one
of them now is a case involving
investigators the judicial system etc
and the people who incited this stuff at
least so far have suffered no
consequences whatsoever we're going to
follow this case and others as they go
forward
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount
join pacman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today jefferson morley who is an author
editor of the blog jfk facts and editor
of the deep states website his next book
is called scorpions dance the president
the spymaster and watergrade watergate
rather uh it's great to have you on
jefferson thank you
thanks for having me david so the um
presidents for some time
have uh opted not to
release the so-called jfk papers there
was initially of quite a long delay put
in place in terms of releasing them to
the public donald trump uh and joe biden
have uh taken positions on that that
have led to significant speculation
about what may be in these files and
these papers um there are a number of
what we might colloquially call
conspiracy theories that exist around
the the murder of jfk as i'm sure you
know and uh the the issue of the files
has only has only fed that talk to us
about what do we know about these files
and what are the the reasons at least as
stated as to their being kept private
okay thank you david let's step back and
just look at what the law says that
it's it's a little complicated so it's
worth explaining to understand how we've
gotten to this moment yes in 1992
oliver stone released his movie jfk
which was with an a-list hollywood cast
a very smart screenplay a very
compelling piece of cinema portrayed
kennedy's assassination as the work of a
high-level conspiracy
this triggered outrage in washington
indignation uh severe attacks on oliver
stone which continued to this day
um
saying he had taken liberties with
history and all of that stone responded
with a very effective response which is
if the government isn't hiding anything
why is it hiding so much and he pointed
out that in 1992 nearly 30 years after
the assassination of the president
80 of the government's records on the
subject were entirely classified
he put that in
in the trailer at the end of the movie
and he said if you're upset about this
you know call your congressman and so um
that resulted in a flood of mail to
capitol hill and congress actually did
the right thing they said we're going to
release all these records to quell all
this speculation and so they passed a
very strong law called the jfk records
act um it passed unanimously imagine
that david unanimously something that
would never happen in today's political
environment but pretty much everybody
across the political spectrum agreed all
jfk records should be made public and so
the law created an independent board to
go and ask government
agencies for their records the board
reviewed them and released them publicly
the agencies the cia the fbi uh
the pentagon they had the right to
request the delay of the release of
certain materials based on their
concerns about national securities
privacy and all that
so
that was a very effective law and in the
1990s we got a huge batch of new records
about the jfk assassination which really
changed
understanding deepened our understanding
of what exactly happened on november 22
1963
when president kennedy was assassinated
and these records illuminated a couple
of things that were not known before
just how much the cia knew about lee
harvey
propaganda operations around oswald both
before and after the assassination so we
learned a lot from those materials
after 25 years all of everything was
supposed to be made public congress
wrote in a sunset provision after 25
years
the agencies have the right to delay
release of information but they can't
postpone it forever and after 25 years
everything should be made secret i mean
made public so 1992 you go to forward
fast forward 25 years october 2017
the final release of jfk records falls
to donald trump
trump goes on twitter and says
uh all jfk
files have been released ahead of time
okay not surprisingly that statement was
false all the jfk records were not
released and they were not released
ahead of time when the dust cleared and
we figured out what had happened what
what had happened was mike pompeo cia
director went to trump and said we
cannot possibly release all of these
records and christopher wray from this
fbi said the same thing and so they
prevailed on trump to continue to delay
the release of this material which by
law was supposed to become public for
another four years
so um we have some idea what's in those
records um
a lot of those records have been
declassified maybe except for a word or
a paragraph so we know something about
what's in these records four years later
the decision falls to joe biden last
month
and on late on the night of october 22nd
biden the white house announced that
nothing
would be released this year
the second time that the deadline
written into the law approved
unanimously by congress for the second
time the federal agencies blew the
deadline
right and um
oh sorry we kind of lost connection with
their every second
the records that remain
yeah jefferson your connection kind of
went in and out there your connection
went in and out there and so we we got
99 of what you said there uh let let me
sort of frame up my my next question
here um
the speculation of course is that
the full release unredacted of
everything would it would tell us the
truth about the assassination itself
whereas more measured perspectives are
well
there's potentially stuff in these
documents related to for example
operation northwoods or other things
that don't really relate to the
assassination itself what do you believe
is
still unknown so to speak
well i i think what we've learned from
from the disclosures in the 1990s is
that the official story
that some guy came out of nowhere and
shot the president for no reason that
story's false
lee harvey oswald the man accused of
doing the killing was very very well
known at the upper ranks of the cia so
in my perspective some people say and
people it's a it's a it's a plausible
argument it's a fair argument that
they're hiding all of this stuff but
there's nothing really important in
there nothing really germane to the
assassination itself right okay
that's a plausible argument but i don't
believe it for a couple of reasons one
if you look at how much was hidden
before now
the agencies lose the presumption of
innocence because they every step before
this
secrecy has hidden highly significant
information
so to say the last round of secrecy does
not involve highly significant
information of course it's possible i
haven't seen the records
but based on the past history i don't
think that that's warranted okay the
second thing is is that these records
could i'm not
i'm not going to say they're going to
rearrange our understanding of the
assassination people have deeply felt
beliefs about the assassination and may
not change their mind no matter what the
evidence but i think that there is
evidence that will change
decisively clarify i guess i would put
it that way so for example what do i
think is in there
i think
is evidence that shows that a certain
group of cia officers targeted lee
harvey oswald for operational purposes
before the assassination and if that's
true that could well be part of a
conspiracy to kill the president so i
think that will will the will it show
you know what happened in dealey plaza
these records will not shed new light on
what happened in dealey plaza what they
will shed new light on is what the cia
knew about this
the accused assassin and the
circumstances of the assassination
before and after kennedy was killed
that's where we see evidence of
malfeasance or misconduct and that's
what these records could decisively show
okay so let's explore that a little bit
less okay so um
one very black and white story that some
tell is the cia
ran in operation directed lee harvey
oswald to assassinate john f kennedy
okay that that's one story
what you're suggesting seems to be it
could be
that lee harvey oswald was not only
known to the cia
but was actually previously
used by the cia
in certain operations not having to do
with the assassination
maybe the cia even was aware that lee
harvey oswald maybe wanted to kill the
president i'm sort of just speculating
here and maybe the cia didn't stop him
or something but you're not necessarily
saying it's a directed assassination
well i haven't seen the record so no i
understand i understand yeah yeah what
what you're saying is possible
that that what they're hiding is they're
hiding incompetence sure not hiding
incriminating information right okay
i i think that's possible again i doubt
it because first of all first of all
if if that was the feeling inside the
cia like oh you know we screwed up we
missed this guy we should have
you know we could have you might see
some trace of that mentality in the
records
okay
there is nothing there is no evidence to
confirm that in the available record
that that's why they are doing what they
are doing so that's one reason why i
doubt it nobody in the cia has ever said
oh we screwed up about oswald if you
look at their behavior it is much more
consistent with this guy is part of a
covert operation that we cannot talk
about and so what i'm saying is i think
there's an undisclosed cia operation
around oswald whose purposes we don't
know and whose purpose is the cia does
not want to disclose
from there if that's true we will have a
better understanding of how to assess
the conspiracy question let's pause our
conversation there with jefferson morley
full interview will be on youtube we'll
take a quick break and be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show so gb news spent days
promoting a supposedly blockbuster
incredible groundbreaking interview with
donald trump conducted by british
politician and broadcaster nigel farage
and i have to tell you this is one of
the most bonkers off-the-wall interviews
i've ever seen trump do it's essentially
100 an interview about cultural issues
like cancel culture and what does trump
think about meghan markle antifun black
lives matter comes up in this first clip
and even right off the bat here trump
jumping right into police related stuff
which is just crazy
because police were attacked by his
supporters on january 6th
no mention or support of those officers
but plenty of mentions of it was
actually antifa and blm who did bad
stuff take a look at this just off the
wall alternate reality
now either way we've got biden and
harris in office and they've got
plummeting poll ratings and we've got a
border crisis as you quite rightly said
remember plum everything here is sort of
a lie plummeting poll ratings still
higher than trump
and the border crisis where essentially
nothing has really changed since trump
left
law and order
um the black lives matter movement which
is now becoming increasingly i think
political don't you
well it's shocking that it started off
uh you know with pigs in a blanket right
you know that right you know the
expression fry them like bacon
and they were i was about our police our
great police and all of us the great
police where trump doesn't say anything
about the police that were tased and etc
on january 6 by his supporters this
becomes mainstream i don't really think
so
and uh antifa bad very bad bad and they
had antifa in that rally they had antifa
leading a lot of people on that day on
january no evidence of that whatsoever
and i will say that uh it's pretty
incredible that nothing happens to them
but the other side this has been going
on for many years there is no evidence
that antifa individuals committed crimes
on january 6. that's why there are no
cases against them they're not just
about they're not just about racial
equality then
well i think they're about politics but
i think they're about a lot of other
things if you go back to their original
founding of what they were saying
kill the police what they're saying is
kill the police
and that becomes mainstream
not good not good says donald trump next
clip
um
donald trump claims that now we aren't
globally respected anymore we have
objective data about that
the u.s reputation was lower than ever
under trump
it has now recovered to some degree
under biden is biden perfect no is his
foreign policy the stuff of dreams no
but by every measure the us
is more respected now than under trump
but trump doesn't care
but biden g7 biden turns up at the g7
and this was before he let everybody
down in afghanistan and and which which
leaves us wondering where is america in
the world now i mean we've got big
threats haven't we we've got a lot of
russian troops
on the ukrainian border we've got china
uh ever more bellicose in their
statements about taiwan we've got iran i
mean can you believe it negotiations are
going on this week with iran and the
israelites and the israelis are very
very scared where is america in the
world right now i think it's at the
lowest point it's ever been at there is
no objective way to defend that
statement it is objectively a lie
i don't think it's ever been in a
position like this we're not respected
anymore i will tell you there were no
planes flying over taiwan and the the
name wasn't even mentioned you didn't
talk about taiwan when i was president
it wasn't going to happen what they're
doing now trump knows nothing about
taiwan that's why he wasn't talking
about it and then wait till after the
olympics i assume and perhaps something
will happen
but it's not good if you're there and
you have bombers flying over your so
trump just wrong there is
the reputation of the u.s has started to
recover it's not perfect it's not
perfect but it is start it was at the
bottom under trump where trump wasn't
even party to many important global
discussions including on climate as
we've mentioned before
um okay next clip in this one trump says
something let's see if we can figure out
what it is even that trump is saying
here
i'm not a fan of hers at all
this is the meghan markle clip
in this clip trump says he's not a fan
of meghan markle okay
i'm not a fan of hers at all and i think
she's very disrespectful to the queen
that we just spoke about yeah who's such
a great woman who's such a great person
a historic person i think she's very
disrespectful to the royal family
but maybe most importantly to the queen
and what's wild about this is you know
meghan markle and her husband one of the
princes i don't i don't care about the
royals they made a decision together
right i mean about separating from the
kind of traditional life of the royal
family but trump's not a fan of meghan
markle specifically kind of just all
very weird then here's a strange clip
trump says something was a big mistake
let's see if we can figure out what it
is that trump says was a big mistake
i heard you through i guess through
twitter um it was was for you you know
something that you used to massive
effect oh jack dorsey is being removed
as ceo of twitter because of shareholder
pressure but whether that means they'll
improve
as a channel or not and i was amazed the
day that the taliban you mentioned
afghanistan a moment ago the day the
taliban took over kabul i did put out a
message that said it seemed ridiculous
that their leadership was still active
on twitter
and yet you were still bad well they
were wrong in what they did and we're
dealing with the united states president
who's obviously a popular so when he
says they were wrong is he talking about
the taliban or twitter like it's not
totally clear to him president from
based on everything that you see and and
them and facebook and i think they made
a big mistake i think if they had it
today okay i guess he's saying if
twitter and facebook had a do-over about
banning him i think over again they
wouldn't be doing it uh we are
uh you know we get the voice out we have
to do it we have a an obligation to do
that
but he's leaving i guess it was probably
enforced because they're down and also
there's no excitement on twitter anymore
okay so i guess he's saying jack dorsey
is leaving because twitter isn't doing
so well it's all just very you know what
are you talking about dude
trump is asked about 2024 he seems to be
signaling that he is running
why on earth would he consider going
back into that hell again so i love our
country
i brought the country to a level it's
never seen before right then we had
kovit come in and then i brought it back
came up with vaccines that you're using
we're all using the world is using saved
tens of millions of people throughout
the world so now he's for the vaccines
in less than nine months it was supposed
to take 12 years now it was never
supposed to take 12 years we knew from
the start these vaccines would be based
on an mrna platform the platform had
been researched for decades
nobody thought what trump is saying is
there are times in history
where the development of some vaccines
could take 10 to 12 years often six to
eight
nobody ever thought it was going to take
12 years with the mrna vaccines you just
heard the other day they're expecting it
to take 12 years and everyone said it
wasn't going to work and they work
incredibly well we've done an amazing
job
if you love the country you have no
choice it's not a question it's just
this is a wonderful beautiful life
but i like that too because i was
helping people that's why i did it
and
i think you'll be happy in the future
too so trump again with this idea of if
you love the country you got to run and
i think you're going to be happy in the
future he seems to be signaling he's
going to be running and then finally no
trump interview is complete without
trump bragging about the size of his
crowds
so looking ahead
you know from here
is the message to look back
on november 2020 and to condemn and
criticize much of what happened
or is the message to look forward and
try and make sure that that that
weakness in the system can't exist i
think it's both i think it has to be
both we have a base
in alabama as an example at 69 000
people recently show up
wherever i go we get i think i'm getting
bigger crowds now at the rallies and you
know the rise because you've been to
plenty
i have the biggest crowds i've ever had
when he says now by the way he had when
with the he hasn't done a rally in
months and months and months so a wacky
wacky interview but the big takeaways
trump's still bragging about the same
stuff without any basis
and he seems to be leaning towards
running in 2024 i don't want to spend a
ton of time on this but joe rogan seems
to sort of have crossed the rubicon in
some sense where joe rogan has always
been interested in conspiracy theories i
also am interested in them joe rogan
seems to believe in more than i do but
there's a difference in what i'm going
to play for you today and something like
the moon landing was faked joe rogan's
new idea is that there is a concerted
effort to restrict access to monoclonal
antibodies so that people will get
vaccinated so that big pharma will make
money i'm going to explain to you why
this makes no sense but this is now over
the line into something that is truly
quite dangerous here's the thing i'm
going to say this because it's [ __ ]
true because i've experienced it many
many times with many people that i'm
friends with they're withholding
monoclonal antibodies they're trying to
stop people from getting them there's
not a [ __ ] shortage of monoclonal
energy so what does that do monoclonal
antibodies kills covid like raid kills
roaches
when you get shot after you get you get
covered then you get this that's what
they gave trump and that's what they
gave me
i got i got better quick
i got better [ __ ] quick and trump got
better pretty quick pretty quick and
he's old and fast
he's always fat and he got better in
four days so why are they withholding it
because they want you to get vaccinated
that's what i think i think they don't
want there to be a very clear path
where you don't have to be vaccinated
but if you get sick you're going to be
fine so so or is it just the money going
into the pharmaceutical companies that's
driving people to want everyone to get
vaccinated or must have an influence
it's also the narrative there's also
people that have been vaccinated that
don't want people to get away without
being vaccinated because i think they
know they took a chance i think secretly
they know like if anybody pays any
attention they know someone who's had a
bad reaction to the vaccine so this this
really is wacky um let's go through it
piece by piece right so first joe rogan
says there's an artificial shortage of
the monoclonal antibodies
if you research how the vaccines are
made and how the monoclonal antibodies
are made
right now
there is a much more limited ability to
generate monoclonal antibodies for the
same number of people as vaccine doses
have been made that's just a fact of
production so that the first thing is
that there's an artificial shortage
there is simply not the availability
because of the production process for
monoclonal antibodies versus vaccines
widely documented this stuff is all out
in the open you can find it
then he says the monoclonal antibodies
have ev it just you just you just get
rid of it it just cures you we have
randomized controlled trials with
monoclonal antibodies they are
efficacious it is not a silver bullet
it is not a silver bullet and if you are
in a situation where you need monoclonal
antibodies you are far better off being
vaccinated so understand that the two
first claims there is an artificial
shortage demonstrably untrue
it simply kills covid not true it's
effective it's an effective treatment
okay
also by the way
then he goes into the financial he says
there's a financial it must be jocko
says what's the point here why
it's fine is it financial and rogan says
it must be
the vaccines are made by pharmaceutical
companies which make money from from
vaccines
the monoclonal antibodies are made by
pharmaceutical companies that make money
from monoclonal antibodies the sa you
can't ascribe a profit motive to one and
not the other
it's for-profit
pharmaceutical companies making both
so it's a wacky claim to make and in
addition to that
the vaccine the pfizer vaccine is now
fully approved by the fda the monoclonal
antibodies are authorized for emergency
use when when we say well we don't know
we really i mean if you want to make
that case we now know more from a from a
regulatory standpoint
about the pfizer vaccine than the
monoclonal antibodies but that is
missing and then lastly
you know everybody
vaccinated people want the unvaccinated
to get a vaccine
because they want others to take a risk
the way they that is crazy
that is crazy
there is no evidence of that whatsoever
and everyone knows someone who's had a
bad reaction i don't know anyone who's
had a bad reaction
um
i mean i know people who were flu-like
for 24 hours i was
um
my girlfriend's arm got red for a little
while
for like eight hours or something like
that
i don't i don't know anybody who's had
really a bad so it's it's so silly and
unfortunately it's going over a line
into something that now is getting much
more dangerous than
you know jfk or or or flat earth or not
that not that rogan believes all this
stuff but
some of this stuff is more benign
um this this is very much not we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p here's a very aggressive
voicemail question yes david uh just uh
curious i watch your show from time to
time
i was curious as to why you never talked
about hunter biden yeah and all the
millions of dollars that he has received
from china and russia
and the fact that that is probably why
joe biden does not
take any action towards either one of
those countries because he has been
compromised yeah listen so first of all
most of the things that this caller said
who interestingly sounds a lot like troy
york and also calls from illinois but
apparently is a different caller first
of all those claims are essentially all
unproven
it's unproven that hunter biden received
money from those governments
there is an investment firm co-founded
by hunter biden which did have a
consulting agreement with the mayor of
moscow it involves a whole bunch of
other people there is no evidence that
joe biden got any money or that joe
biden is involved in any way
and most importantly hunter biden isn't
involved in the administration in any
way you know ivanka trump eric trump don
jr they were highly present in donald
trump's administration they were sitting
at the table ivanka sat at the table at
what was it the g8 or the g20 or
whatever it was filling in for then
secretary of state rex tillerson um and
these very same people that now want to
draw some link to joe biden from things
hunter biden did in the past
allegedly and hunter has no involvement
whatsoever in joe biden's administration
where were they on ivanka eric don jr
and jared kushner during the trump
administration these people are pathetic
and there is really no what what am i
going to
hunter but what do you want me to talk
about hunter biden the guy's nowhere
he's com he's not present in any way or
involved at all
uh we've got a great bonus show for you
today
i won't even tell you what's on today's
bonus show it's a good one sign up at
joinpakman.com and you'll get instant
access
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to two hundred
dollars off and two free pillows at
helix sleep dot com slash pacman